one of the biggest sort of philosophical
or ideological battles that's happening
right now within the left and even to
some degree within the progressive left
is about the approach to making change
how do you get changed to happen and we
can sort of a roughly coarsely sum up
the two positions by saying fix the
system or burn the system down and
create a new one once you've burnt down
the system that we have now it's an
oversimplification it's how we are
oversimplifying today in order to have
this discussion there's more nuance to
it than that but in a large sense this
is it do you believe the system works
well enough that you would try to make
changes to it or do you believe that the
system is so broken that it has to first
fail or be destroyed before real change
can be made now from day one when we
talked about for example about two
candidates neither of whom ended up
being the Democratic nominee Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders we talked
about how on policy they end up in
pretty similar places on a lot of issues
but their approaches are very different
Bernie came from the 70s hippie further
left revolution mentality and was kind
of pulled towards moderation in terms of
a lot of his policy over time Warren
came from the opposite place Warren came
from a much more centrist or even
center-right position and eventually was
pulled to the left where her policies
under ended up being similar to Bernie
in many ways but she is in the the
mindset of fix the system work within
the system make changes to the system
today I want to talk only about what has
worked in the history of the United
States so this is not an analysis of any
candidate this is not a moral judgment
about any candidate this is not an
analysis of any particular policy that
we're looking at it is only historically
which approach has worked for achieving
change that moved the country to the
left working within the system or burn
it down build it back up more of a
revolutionary style approach we can call
it whatever you
none of these are pejoratives I think we
sort of understand what what we're
talking about here and it certainly
links more to the ideology more of the
Bernie Sanders supporter in the context
of the Democratic primary now as I've
said before the paradigm that has
brought us the most progressive change
in history is making changes to the
system that we have rather than
revolution and burning it down now that
being said there have been times when
the type of burn it down change that
somewhat has happened but I am going to
make the case today that those big
revolutionary moments have come after
horrible events what I would call
Cataclysm that includes endless death
and we'll get to that in a little bit so
let's start by looking at the successes
there are three major eras of
progressive leftward advancement in the
United States that we can look at we can
look at the progressive era of the 1890s
to the 1920s we can look at the New Deal
era between 1933 and 1939 and exactly
how you define these eras you know
there's some leeway and then the civil
rights era of the mid-1950s
to roughly 1965 so let's look at each of
these and see which category they fall
into the Progressive Era at the turn of
the 20th century was catalyzed by
activism
and demand for social reform going
through every achievement of the
Progressive Era would be sort of
difficult impractical but the reforms of
the Progressive Era dealt with
corruption dealt with labor and labor
rights dealt with antitrust with women's
voting of course expanding labor policy
and labor unions a whole bunch of
bureaucratic stuff that was really
important including things like
municipal reform and it was all
catalyzed by the idea of we've got to
build up the middle class and
economically that will be good
morally it's the right thing to do and
we've got to put in some safety net
elements for the poor it all happened by
tweaking
system now the thing is progress can
seem slow when you're in it and in fact
this was a thirty year period that's a
long time now from 2020 it's easy to
look back and say wow look at all that
stuff that they accomplished so quickly
but thirty years is a long time and I
encourage you to look at the full list
of accomplishments when you're in the
middle of big change thirty years seems
very very slow looking back though we
realized even though it was done by
community activism by slowly getting a
more favorable Supreme Court it led to
major change now let me give you an
example of that a lot of the Progressive
Era reforms were upheld at the Supreme
Court because of justice Charles Evans
Hughes joining with Oliver Wendell
Holmes okay
Herbert Hoover nominated Charles Evan
huge Hughes Teddy Roosevelt nominated
Oliver Wendell Holmes so when we say
would trump or Biden select a better
replacement for Ruth Bader Ginsburg and
would it matter just look at how much
this stuff matters look at who got to
pick Supreme Court justices that led to
Progressive Era reforms and it was all
tweaks tweaks tweaks and over 30 years
it transformed the country that's
example number one let's look at example
number two of fix the system rather than
tear it down the New Deal era of the
1930s under Franklin Delano Roosevelt
this came out of the Great Depression it
included changes that now are considered
to be part of the fabric of the country
like the Social Security Administration
but they were not burn it down
revolution type changes it was regulate
the banking industry by putting the
right regulators in place create
programs to support farmers and the
unemployed
support young people and elderly folks
creating social security you don't get
that by burning down the system they got
it by taking more control of the system
regulating securities trading the
Housing Act of 1937 building labor power
on top of the changes of the Progressive
Era
it wasn't burn it down it was not
revolution it was six to seven years of
chain
from a center-left president now I'll go
even further this is important when it
comes to the New Deal era the New Deal
era was so much not a revolutionary
phase that there were people at the time
saying FDR is not even center-left he's
a centrist and the New Deal is merely a
smokescreen to reinforce capitalism as a
system that's how much not of a
revolution the New Deal was although of
course I don't buy into that cynical
interpretation and important change
happened over a seven-year period third
the civil rights era the civil rights
era was filled with protests and sit-ins
and rallies and a ton of the day-to-day
elements that we often today recognize
would likely be needed in order to
achieve more change and achieve it more
quickly but look at the process 1954 you
got the Brown v Board of Education
decision that was an early moment in the
civil rights era and it was a decision
made again by the Supreme Court
reinforcing the importance of who gets
to pick those justices that continues to
be a theme here 1956 the n-double-a-cp
works within the judiciary to win
desegregation of the bus system 1957
Martin Luther King creates the SCLC to
support local protest movements and
achieve change at the local level in
North Carolina we had the drugstore
sit-in in 1960 which sparked a bigger
era of sit-ins to continue making small
changes legally during the judiciary at
the legal ocol state and national level
in 63 you get the march on Washington it
demands jobs it demands it's a new fight
against discrimination which was
demanding change from the government not
trying to take it down and cause a
revolution ultimately this led to the
Civil Rights Act of 1964 now was that
the end was that the be-all end-all of
fighting against racial discrimination
no we're still in that process today but
the point is the great errors of
progress were
burn it down moments last thing I want
to mention here when there have been
these bigger burn it down type moments
of radical fast change they've typically
been very bloody and came out of
Cataclysm example the civil war civil
war went from 1861 to 1865 if in 1855
right about five years before the Civil
War you had said you know in six years
the country will almost be torn apart
over the issue of slavery a multi-year
war will ensue during which more than
600,000 people will die we will just
barely be held together but big change
will come of it we all of course would
welcome the end result which is slavery
is no longer allowed but when you look
at when things move more quickly in the
more revolutionary way there is endless
death and destruction and to think about
causing it deliberately is questionable
and it took you know when you look at
reconstruction twelve years in the
United States because of the Civil War
it achieved a great victory no question
about it it also brought incredible
Cataclysm to the United States and
sometimes it is the only way that's
what's really important and of course
the North the Union fighting in the
Civil War of course they were on the
right side and of course the right
outcome came from it but what history
tells us is that if we want to expand
health care increased social reforms
regulate industry the victories have
come not from the Cataclysm of the type
that the Civil War sort of checks a box
under it's come from the reform of the
Progressive Era
the New Deal era the civil rights era
and the like tell me where I'm wrong
this is my perspective I welcome other
other perspectives respectfully and with
peace and love I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman I want to hear from you quick
break back after this if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always struggling to find the
time check out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blink
blinka slits you consume an entire book
on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video